is a difference between a lack of
expertise and inexperience
right we think we lack expertise in
something but actually we're just
inexperienced at it and that's the point
of that second element of you don't have
to be the best at something when you
start doing it but as soon as you start
doing it you've now given yourself that
opportunity to grow and I think we all
know this there's always something we've
all learned and become better at it but
if you're fascinated by it you're
probably more likely to invest more time
but it is also important there may be
things in your life that you have an
expertise in but you don't have a
passion in but then ask yourself the
question
why don't I have a passion here because
you could add meaning to it like there
are so many skills that we have that if
you added a bit of meaning you added
some purpose to it you added why you
were doing it you could actually find a
great use for it and I think a lot of us
are underestimating how powerful
expertise is you may have strengths that
are just underutilized by your current
job but actually it could be really well
utilized by someone that you felt
activated you